they look like attacks but moscow
insists they're not saying the blasts in
crimea and belarus were either accidents
or technical malfunctions now keeve has
not publicly claimed any responsibility
here but the ukrainian president and his
cabinet they have seized upon events to
shape the narrative in ukraine's favor
ukraine's allies are in step with that
message i want you to take a listen to
what the uk defense minister said
earlier today
russia are starting to fail in many
areas they have failed so far and are
unlikely to ever succeed in occupying uh
ukraine their invasion has faltered and
constantly been remodified to the extent
they are really only focusing in parts
of the south and in the east a long long
way away from their three-day so-called
special operation
three days are now over 150 days and
nearly six months in with huge
significant losses of both equipment
and indeed russian personnel
yeah now back to those explosion or that
explosion in belarus belarus is playing
down reports of overnight blasts at a
military air base near its border with
ukraine the belarusian defense ministry
said an engine caught fire and that
there were no casualties
fraunhofer a senior adviser to
belarusian exiled opposition leader
svetlana
he has a different account of events
and he is my first guest tonight frank
it's good to have you back on
the day
tell me what have you heard
about what happened in belarus do do you
know who was responsible for what
happened
i know we don't know who is responsible
yesterday
perhaps at 11 12 p.m
we received information from multiple
sources about
the explosions about the blasts about
the flashes people saw it near zebra
captain also within homily region
and
it's definitely not the fire on the
engine
these people they took pictures they do
video of the blast we try to identify
things behind it to immediately send
information and requests to our contacts
in modern determined but unfortunately
it's very difficult to understand was it
military drill or was it attack or was
it partisan sabotage diversion we don't
know for sure but official statement
from ministry of defense of lukashenko
is that it was just the fire of engine
yeah and there is no mention at all in
the official explanation
of the possibility of the explosion
being the result of a ukrainian attack
right
of course and uh
and i we do we can't expect that uh
official regime propaganda will say that
it's ukrainian army who attacked us
definitely not but this can be all for
the parties of the time there could be
also the act of sabotage uh that could
be also the
mistake of russian military who are
behaving like their host in belarus and
since february 2022 they created
multiple dangerous situations uh in the
homeland breast region bordering with
ukraine
in the fronic it remains almost
impossible to verify reports on the
ground in belarus and it's the same in
crimea i mean how worried are you that
the fog of war
could create unrealistic expectations
among the ukrainian people as well as
the people in belarus who are against
this war
absolute majority of belarusians don't
want belarus to be dragged into this war
there is a huge fear last two years we
were afraid of repressions of terror now
people are afraid of war and lukashenko
and putin's regime they are trying to
drag belarus and belarus army into this
conflict uh but belarusian nation the
recent population even the recent
officers they resist they do all
possible to prevent it this provocation
this explosions yesterday could be also
the provocation in order to force the
kashanka's regime and belarus army to
enter
the war in ukraine but
i hope it won't happen i mean do you do
you think
that that is a possibility that
ukraine could be trying
to force belarus to get into the war i
mean where do you think that
that pressure is coming from
uh ukraine definitely doesn't want
belarus to enter this war ukraine
doesn't want russia to use belarus
territory the ukrainian government
recently demonstrates a lot of signs of
solidarity with savannah scandals
national leader of villains and the
democratic movement and definitely they
do all possible to prevent lukashenko
from from entering this war but the
question is how much ukrainian army can
do how much our partisans can do in
march and april our partisans stopped
russian trains
several partisans are facing right now
death penalty because of these sabotage
attacks um
now we are trying to strengthen this
underground movement but regime is so
cruel people are arrested every day
for every anti-war command for every
award in support of ukraine
an adviser to ukrainian president
vladimir zelinski he has again
issued a thinly veiled warning to russia
and its ally
belarus
and let me just read that for you the
epidemic of technical
accidents at military airfields of
crimea and belarus should be considered
by russia's military as a warning forget
about ukraine take off the uniform and
leave neither in occupied crimea nor in
occupied belarus will you feel safe
karma
finds you anywhere there's a very strong
words there frantic this of course is
ukrainian government messaging it sounds
like ukraine believes that it is now
winning this war is that how you see it
ukraine is definitely winning the
information space it's definitely a
winning international reaction and
international organizations but in terms
of the front line it's not so clear yet
but we want ukraine to win because when
ukraine wins prevails over russia it
will create chance for galleries to get
liberated to get free as well right now
the fates of belarus and europeans are
so interconnected as never in history
and we do all possible to support
ukraine we support volunteers military
volunteers fighting in ukraine because
we know we know that this support
will help them to win and their victory
will help us to win over dictatorship
you and i have spoken before about the
german government and how it was
criticized for dragging its feet
with shipments of weapons to ukraine
when this invasion began
the german chancellor he was accused of
not being tough enough on russia i want
you to take a listen to what chancellor
schultz said today
the biggest challenge is a terrible war
that russia started against ukraine that
has already lasted many months
it means we have to make far-reaching
decisions to support ukraine in its
fight for independence
as you know we are doing that with a
massive break with our previous policy
by delivering weapons very very many
very efficient long-range
and we weapons continue to do that in
future we are supporting ukraine
financially and we have reconciled
ourselves with this war affecting the
whole world europe and our countries
the german chancellor's strong words are
another very positive
signal for the ukrainians do you think
the ukrainian forces are now
in possession of the weapons that they
need to begin pushing the russians back
it will never be enough of course the
delivery of german-american
british and canadian
weapons is very very important but we
are dealing with a cruel empire with
militaristic regime of putin which has
so much uh arms weapons equipment that
remained after soviet union that uh
everything that was done already is not
enough so i think the delivery must
continue ukraine must receive everything
they want but also not only ukraine also
the underground movement underground
resistance in countries like belarus
also must be supported and we are
grateful to german government residents
office
and they promised to do all possible to
support belarusians who fight against
putin's and lukashenkos regime
the ukrainian president zielinski he
says that this war will end only when
the annexation of crimea
is over is that a realistic goal
considering the russian position
russia will get weaker and weaker it
will get exhausted after some time you
know this regime they
they are looking uh invincible until
they are not and we must be optimistic
yes there will be a very difficult
winter many people will have to pay
bigger
prices
taxes but this is the price we pay for
many years of
neglection of such regime
i'm sure that
putin's regime will lose
in russia is not happy russian oligarchs
and russian society is getting also not
so happy so we just have to be ready to
use the window of opportunity and to
turn this energy in russia against
putin's regime and you know before we
run out of time chronic you know we hear
so much about what is at stake with with
the outcome of this war particularly for
ukraine but what about belarus
um a democratic
reform in belarus
is that possible as long if if russia
loses this war will it be possible for
belarus to have
democratic reforms
and
is it possible as long as vladimir putin
is still in charge in russia
uh changes in batteries are possible
earlier than changes in russia
russia doesn't recognize the
independence and the statehood of
belarus and ukraine and this is why in
2020 when our revolution started putin
supported lukashenko back then in 2020
when crackdown on civil society happened
we didn't know that the plan to attack
ukraine was already in the head of putin
and everything that was happening in
belarus it was a preparation for attack
on kiev by vladimir putin and lukashenko
was already complicit of putin in this
operation
the accord as always we appreciate your
time and your insights tonight thank you
thank you